here you are 15 years later Mia's gone
on this incredible journey for you as an
actor what's that been like for you
it's been amazing I think I recently got
asked like does it make it easier to
play the same role over the years and I
think what you have to watch what I have
to watch is that you don't get lazy like
I on Fast & Furious Five there was so
much that I kind of went back and
watched one and four four yeah four and
I just I tried to like revisit it to see
like where we had been and sort of you
know - that was my way of preparing so
it's fun when you sort of have a
catalogue of stuff to look at and the
idea this time Mia you know that they
never short shrift the women in these
stories which is kind of lovely when you
consider its action in cars and you have
all this testosterone and both you and
Michelle have great arcs here Nia has
has a lot going on she does Mia's like
it's amazing to me because she's so
stoic and selfless and so different from
I mean my response if my husband were in
danger my brother in danger I'd be like
you guys let's hole in and like no one's
going anywhere but she's like you guys
have to go out there and deal with this
and come back to your family and it
always amazes me how how stoic she is
and brave she really and she's kind of
like the voice of reason and the brand
I think she's always telling the guys
especially Brian and Dom like here's
what you have to do and sort of pointing
them in the right direction and bigger
isn't always necessarily better but it
seems as each film comes out there they
are bigger they're stronger there's more
going on help out he described this one
I think in a sense I mean James brought
a really different sensibility to it
which is really nice to see I don't he
didn't make the mistake of like I mean
it is bigger but it's not insane I feel
like you still cuz you never want to
lose the audience's ability to suspend
their disbelief we never want to jump
the shark in that way and so far we
haven't which is amazing well while
doing these insane stunts so I think
what what keeps the film grounded is the
characters and their relationships and
James paid such attention to especially
Letty and Dom's relationship in this
story I think that was it was such a
nice turn from all the other fast
furious
and we've always known that DOM and Mia
have this wonderful bond but in this one
he's there for her it's so much they're
speaking to each other mores like peers
in a way like she's sort of bouncing
ideas off of him and now that was a
really nice scene at the Toronto House I
really liked it because they say it's
not like I think in the past she's
always advising him or he's advising her
and and they're always in harm's way but
in this it was way more like familiar
and something I think people can relate
to in a sense so it's really nice is it
fair to say it's that way with you and
then as well it is in a big way it's
really nice it's been I often confide in
him and
it's rare with VIN that like you have
quick conversations like with VIN
everything goes deeper and deeper and
deeper which is really nice me as a mom
now she has a toddler you're a parent
now yeah can you does it in any way
change your up your approach it
completely changes my approach to be a
mom I mean there was a scene we shot
with Jack where he's in danger and I
think you know as an actress you try to
approximate what something feels like
and empathize but just envisioning my
son in a car that was I just it makes
everything so much more visceral so when
I'm just screaming and running towards
that car I just I think it was far more
real and now that I can relate to that
so much more I'm you talked about James
a little bit earlier but but what did he
bring to this it was certainly a fresh
set of eyes yeah James I mean the action
was done so well obviously but he also
there were certain things I read in the
script and I was like gosh this is so
different for our audience like I don't
know if they're gonna go with this the
particularly the very emotional things
and he really dealt with them especially
the the flashbacks in such a way that
they weren't too much they weren't sappy
they were really sweet and artfully done
and I thought that was what was that was
that's really tricky and abassin furious
film and he did them so so well
yeah balance is always tricky and in
action film yeah if you don't have heart
if you don't have a motion it doesn't
matter how many cars you crash right no
no you have to care about the characters
and there was a lot of humor in it too I
thought Wayne brought so much humor into
it which is something you also need
gives you kind of like need to take a
breather between all the huge set pieces
and action stunts and all of that
does it ever cease to amaze you the
appetite that audiences around the world
have for these new films when they're
coming out it does amaze me I mean it's
you know it's not something I take for
granted at all but I think I'm starting
to realize that part of the appeal is
that our audience is growing with us in
a sense so I think they they're they're
going on the journey with us and they're
expanding with us so it's kind of we're
kind of in this together which is which
is really nice
you